hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor
in today's video we're going to be
discussing transposable
elements
which are a pretty cool feature
in the human genome and in genomes of
other organisms as well
so what are transposable elements
specifically they are sequences of dna
that can actually move
from one location in the genome to
another location in the genome
and because they can do that move around
in the genome
they have this special name that you may
have heard
of jumping genes
again that's because they can jump from
one place in the genome to somewhere
completely different in the genome
now the process of moving from one place
to another involves recombination
and specifically when we're talking
about transposable elements
this movement is called
transposition
and also transposable elements they are
not always harmless
in fact they are often mutagenic
mutagenic because they can interrupt
other genes
this means that if you have a
transposable element
leave
its original place in the genome and
move to a different place in the genome
sometimes the place to where it moves is
right in the middle of another gene
and by disrupting or interrupting that
other gene that other gene may no longer
be functional
resulting in phenotypic change and
sometimes even disease and so that is
where the immunogenic property comes
from
now there are two different types of
transposable elements
these are transposons
and
retrotransposons let's talk about each
one and how they are
different from each other
transposons
may or may not leave a copy behind that
means that when they move
from one location in the genome to
another
they may leave a copy of themselves in
the old location
we consider that a kind of copy and
paste mechanism
they may also not leave a copy behind
and have a more cut and paste mechanism
where they leave the old location do not
leave a copy of themselves behind and
just go to the new location
now transposons are able to move because
they encode a gene
for an enzyme called transposase
so transposase is the enzyme that
catalyzes their excision or removal from
the original place
and their reintegration or recombination
into the new location
if you are interested in learning about
how enzymes work how they catalyze these
kinds of
situations then please see my video
titled introduction to enzymes
now let's talk about retrotransposons
these always leave a copy behind
so there is always
a copy of the retro transposon in the
old location
and an identical copy in the new
location
so always a copy and paste mechanism
rather than cut and
paste they use a different kind of
enzyme specifically reverse
transcriptase
and in addition to using reverse
transcriptase they also work through an
rna intermediate
this means that you have
the dna the dna that is the transposable
element
it gets copied
into an rna intermediate
the rna intermediate is then reverse
transcribed by reverse transcriptase
back into dna
and that second portion
of dna is what gets integrated into the
new location in the genome
while the original dna is left behind in
the original position
now you may have heard of this kind of
mechanism before where reverse
transcriptase
is used
to convert an rna intermediate into dna
and that would be
in a type of virus
called
retroviruses and in fact these
retrotransposons
may be evolutionarily related to
retroviruses
retroviruses the most common one you've
heard of probably is hiv
now let's talk about a couple of
examples
of transposable elements
they were first discovered in maze by a
woman named barbara mcclintock who
actually won the nobel prize for her
discovery
it was found that these transposable
elements by jumping around in the genome
could actually interrupt
genes for pigment color
leading to the kernels of the maize
having different colors
transposable elements have also been
found in bacteria and importantly
some transposable elements actually
carry
antibiotic resistance genes
and these genes can move back and forth
from chromosomal dna into plasma dna and
back again
and can can actually create some
some medically
important antibiotic resistant bacteria
now if you're interested in learning
more about antibiotic resistance in
bacteria why it's important how it's
harmful for human health then please see
my video on antibiotic resistant
bacteria
and finally
these transposable elements they're
found in many different organisms
including humans the most common type in
humans are known as alu sequences
and aloe sequences are actually very
very common in the human genome there
are many many many copies of them and
they can
create some health issues they've
actually been linked to several cancers
and that goes back to
the mutagenic properties because these
aloe sequences
can copy themselves and hop around and
interrupt other genes
that interruption can actually result in
a variety of different types of cancers
so that is it for today learning about
transposable elements
i hope you enjoyed this video and thanks
for watching biology professor